e
okay I'd like to go ahead and start with
today's exact sessions uh for the public
we apologize we have a lot going on both
here and of course one of our reps is
now at somewhere else I will be
somewhere else in a few moments as well
so it's going to be a sporadic day in
terms of trying to get some of these
execs done I'd like to First recognize
uh we have a replacement for
representative Ford on our committee now
this is a full-time permanent
replacement we have representative Paul
Terry here and Paul Welcome to our
committee um it it doesn't take as much
time as Commerce does
thank you I've been told that this is a
much more interesting committee so I'm
looking forward to what an interest
means I think I idea that's that's a
good adjective and I'd like to also re
recognize representative David uh price
who is subbing today for represent bone
priest excuse me yeah and welcome and I
hope you enjoy our our day even though
it may be sporadic here so what I'd like
to do is jump right into uh the first
bill which we'd like to uh address and
that is um a commission to study current
funding for special education that's HB
1176 and I'm going to hand the gavel off
to representa cordelli uh thank you Mr
chairman and I call on the chairman for
a motion I'd like to recommend inum
study second second by representative
Miler a discussion from uh the uh maker
of the motion yes I I'll try to be as
timely and quick as possible uh the the
issue of special education is a an issue
which has been upon us for years uh not
just a differentiated Aid component of
special education but catastrophic Aid
and how we fund that and support the
students that receive that type of Aid
and support and we know that the cost of
doing uh special education work in
schools is is costly due to the fact we
have 13 different IEPs some requiring
less time than others and we've
currently fund differentiated Aid at one
level per all IEPs and then when we get
into the business of catastropic Aid it
even is more costly with the formula we
have and you all know that the first
first part is the responsibility of the
school district paying three and a half
times the average cost per pupil for and
that comes right out of um the pockets
of the school district that would be up
to 70 $770,000 if the average cost is at
$20,000 per
kid and thereafter up to 10 times the
state kicks in 80% the local school
district has to give it kick in 20% and
beyond that 10 times the state kicks in
however that leaves the Local District
having to pay an awful lot of money and
there's need for us to look at it we've
had several bills come to us in recent
years dropping cat aid from 2 and 1/2
times I put that from 3 and 1 half to 2
and a/ half times I put that in several
years back that went nowhere
uh we have another one that's come in at
funding at at one and a half times um
we're we're dealing with that uh now
it's time to really get serious and
figure out what we're going to do
interim study is the best way to handle
this rather than a commission a
commission wouldn't get going on it
until probably fall um we need to have
resolution to this as quickly as
possible interim study we can get on it
right now and we can put a group
together and start working out those
areas which need correction and there
are a lot of areas that need support and
correction within how we fund and pay
for uh special education so I I
recommend interim
study uh represent Miler anything uh
thank you Mr chair I've checked with the
uh and conferred with the prime sponsor
of this bill and she agrees uh much
along the same lines as representative
lad has spoken
to thank you anything from the
committee
seen nothing um Madam clerk when you're
ready Vice chairman
cordelli yes representative luus yes
representative Terry yes representative
eler yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath oh representative wock
yes representative Hall yes
representative priest yes representative
cascaden yes representative Damon yes
chairman lad
yes 19 y zero Nays
consent yes
great and uh hand the gavl back over and
uh next bill we will deal with is also
dealing the issue of special education
it's
1509 Excuse me yes prohibiting spending
of special education education money for
any other purpose I'll hand the Gabel
over to represent
cordelli uh thank you um and I'll call
on the chairman for a motion on
1509 I thank you very much I also would
like to recommend interim study for 1509
second second by representative Miler uh
would would the maker like to comment
yes I I would um there there are some
issues and concerns which we have to
look at at this and I thought at the
same time we're
studying uh with the previous bill which
we've just looked at as far as special
education funding event and programming
supporting special education we need to
be cognizant of uh a directive put out
by the US Department of Education it's
coordinating early intervening Services
it's called CIS and it's a guidance uh
memo to school districts and it says
that using these federal funds um they
can be used to provide behavioral
interventions for students positive
behavior interventions and support
initiatives which are you those students
that make the frequent stop at the
principal's door or the principal's
bench uh there's ways to work with
students and the monies can be used to
offset uh going further with um
uh issues that may end up with special
education um also CIS uh might be used
to help funding reading or math
Specialists to work with non-disabled
students who have not reached grade
level or proficiency so you can use
special education monies even though the
student doesn't have an IEP but
demonstrates that they're quote in that
area of remedial reading or remedial
math and they need support so they don't
go the route of special educ
ation monies can also be used for after
school tutoring for non-disabled
students who score below basic or
Statewide assessments so here's another
area that monies can be used and then
I'd like to put my administrator hat on
and I've said it to the committee before
if you're at the end of the year and you
have a balance of money in your accounts
and the fuel tanks are empty and you
know the price of fuel is going up in
coming years do you use use that money
that you have available to you know
offset those costs of fuel and and pay
for the fuel now or do you not put in
some kind of a a trust or whatever and
spend the additional dollars for filling
up the tank later on when you have the
money's appropriated in the next budget
cycle I as an administrator always chose
to fill the tanks
up so that's my uh response to why we
need to interum study this um I
understand the nature and the intent of
the Bill however there's there is
conflicts uh with aspects of the bill
and I think it can be all sorted out
with um a study an interim study along
when we're studying the other for the
special education study on CAD Aid and
differentiated Aid thank you r m uh
thank you Mr chair uh this bill um 1509
can go with
1176 as we look at the whole issue of
special education I think it's a nice
combination that we can look look at the
whole thing whole topic
together thank you uh comments from the
committee I've seen none uh Madam
clerk Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes yes
representative Terry yes representative
beler yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes I'll do that
quickly representative Heath is not here
uh representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
priest yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 19 y zero Nays consent consent great
thank you and back to Chairman and we're
GNA try to do this next I've been text
that the hearing is starting where I
supposed to be HB 1108
uh committee to study the role of
colleges in contributing to student loan
crisis I Look to represent Miler for a
motion I move to it all
this I'll second
it
1108 committee to study the role of
colleges in contributing to student loan
crisis ref I think we've uh debated this
uh Within the committee and we just
ought to move to the
vote any further discussion from the
committee thank you very much Madam
clerk when you're
ready Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Terry
no representative Belcher no
representative dry
yes representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Pell yes representative Corell no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
he uh Heath is not here representative
wock yes representative Hall yes
representative priest yes representative
Kaden yes representative Damon yes
chairman lad yes can I change my
vote
the gavel has not come down okay so yes
no you have no I have written a wrong
note on
my okay so um 13 Ys six Nays thank you
very much the vot Mr chair 13 to six
thank you 13 to
six okay um um I'm going to have to
leave represent he comes in I go
out um I shouldn't be that
long2
that
really this is going to be one of those
days what you do
today you believe it are
you okay so why don't you just go ahead
and move it I I gotta go okay uh the
next bill we will take up is uh House
Bill
1552 uh relative to the duties and
respons responsibilities of
superintendence um excuse me um uh if I
might um if we could hold off on this I
think this is one also that we wanted to
talk to the department about um in
relation to there's a lot of discussion
a lot of discussion about uh single
districts and definition of that and the
department was interested in um talking
about that um as well um and that is
something that we had mentioned uh to
the department to discuss uh this
afternoon so if we could hold off on
that from the Department to discuss them
with us no we're going over there
there's uh like four bills that we are
going to discuss with them this
afternoon no I I missed
that
okay so um I guess uh represent
representative lad did not think he was
going to be long so so we'll just uh
hold until um he
returns so you're free to get up and
walk
around representative Sherry yes hi
representative Damon nice to meet you
meet you so you are now no longer going
to be sitting on Commerce that's
correct yes you off I have list of folks
from
Commerce Insurance sub committee yeah
and you're working on a bill
IIT yes I remember I remember yes so
most impressive yes yes
yes am still trying to have really clear
concise data to show how I don't that
anymore
yes yes that of course not it's not as
powerful it's not convincing
yes I mean the data
exists even though I'm not there
anymore anybody doesn't
know even you may not know you know
diabetes but everyone does yes but most
of us actually know someone diabetes and
know that they have diabetes yes I
think early in Myer a lot of people with
diabetes didn't speak out about it and
that's the best way for them to be able
to take care of themselves I guess I was
fortunate because I would actually have
tell me that they were diabetic if we
were
e
I ask for
reconsideration on that
bill and so uh I'd like to put forth a
motion for reconsideration on
1265 is there a
second second okay discussion on
reconsideration I I can explain
why um we had that was a day that we had
a substitute in on our committee that
shouldn't have been here and so the
broke came out 13
to5 I
believe
13 the seven excuse me 13
to7 and the motion was ought to
pass so so I won't discuss anymore
that's the rationale behind the
reconsideration that's
yes so we're fine with the vote the way
it was at this point we would say no for
reconsideration that is correct okay
thank
you repes Damon you have your hand sort
of up yes thank you um I feel a little
confused
so is there a motion to reconsider yes
we be voting on whether we want to
reconsider the bill or not if you don't
reconsider the bill the bill would stand
as it was voted on by us earlier okay
thank you you're welcome represent
Cornell Thank you does it just make it
more proper to reconsider and then
revote so that
it's I've been told by the clerk's
office we don't all we have to do is ask
for reconsideration the reconsideration
goes down
then that vote would hold thank
you so
not not seeing any further discussion so
the motion is for reconsideration if
you're supporting reconsideration and
reconsidering
1265 you would vote Yes if you're
opposed you would vote
no and
so the motion is for
reconsideration up or
down uh Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative leus no representative
Terry no Representative vure no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
Representative pel no representative
Corell no representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
tenner no representative
Luna no
representative Heath no representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall
no representative Priest No
Representative cascaden
no representative Damon no chairman lad
no one y 19 Nays
okay
apologies this is 1305 you said
yes thank you I would move a to pass on
[Music]
second um yes I was i' like to uh
actually introduce Amendment
2024-25
4H I would move out to pass on the
amendment
sure
thank you Mr chair um this amendment was
the result of the work of the Prime
sponsor of the bill with the Attorney
General's office to just clarify a small
amount of language just to make it clear
and I think the bill itself is is fine
as is but this would just further
highlight that we're not looking to
allow speech on colleges that would
otherwise be prohibited by law such as
threats and incitement to um to violence
or criminal
activity you're presting the
amendment we have a second that
second
am
64 byes mdon now you have the floor
repres thank you Mr chair and uh
everything I just said ditto um it's a
simple amendment that corrects language
that the Attorney General's office had
requested not on the amendment
no
discussion
committee thank you very much Mr chair
my understanding is that the
the community
colleges and the university system and
the Attorney General's office um were
all opposed to the bill as um as drafted
given the fact that the amendment was
drafted in conjunction with the Attorney
General's office does the amendment
address all I'm not asking that IT
addresses the community colleges or the
um University Systems substantial
objections to this bill but does it
address all of the um the Attorney
General's um um opposition to the Bill
thank you and yes I have received the
email thread from the Attorney General's
office saying that this does indeed
address all of their concerns with the
Bill thank you chairman L we're talking
about the just the
amendment oh wait please thank
you
on the amendment this is amendment uh
0654 for
1305 Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Terry yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative petel yes representative
corello yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner yes representative Luna no
representative Heath no representative
Woodcock no representative Hall no
representative Priest No Representative
cascaden
no representative Damon
yes chairman lad yes 12 y eight
n okay represent beler thank you Mr
chair I will speak to
otpa um this bill as amended making a
motion now
PPA uh yes I I would do that then thank
you
second thank you um so this bill as
amended establishes a a floor of
protections for free speech on college
campuses and Association on college
campuses and it really just highlights
that the protections that are generally
afforded by our constitution by our
first amendment to the Constitution do
in fact apply
on college
campuses as are reasonable for the
environment we understand that there
can't be total free speech on college
campuses you can't have students yelling
during class and such like
that um the reason the rationale for
bringing this forward is that is that
this committee has heard um a number of
different times that the approach taken
at some colleges and universities is not
entirely even-handed and it is not
entirely without Viewpoint
discrimination we've heard from students
uh of some small conservative or
organizations testify that they were
subjected to increased degrees of
scrutiny that other organizations were
not we further
heard
sure
understood I think we're all
set we further heard testimony from a
different group a different small
conserv group that they were uh told
they had to shut down a two-person
tabling event because they they failed
to receive a permit and they admitted
they were failed to receive a permit the
university confirmed that it was their
policy to always refuse to allow
unpermitted events to go forward but
when we got our hands on the actual
database of University records for 2023
school year we discovered that there was
an event that was unpermitted that was
allowed to go forward and that one event
all by itself even though the event I
think it should have been allowed to go
forward it demonstrates that their
policy is not being done in an
evenhanded manner there is other
evidence as well in this database that
strongly suggests Viewpoint
discrimination especially against some
of the smaller conservative and
Christian groups and I think it's time
that we step in as a state as we have
been requested to by many
students to establish a baseline level
of freedom of Association and freedom of
speech on college campuses that can be
administered without regard for the
views that are being expressed as long
as they don't violate
law and uh I would I would urge you to
support this thank
you uh thank you um a couple things I'd
like to point out one in in relation to
the database that the member just
brought up I think at the last hearing
the uh College uh refuted a number of
those instances that were raised uh um
um from uh looking at the database and
and bringing in the context of the
situation um I think that this bill is
um has been worked on since the bill
last year and I think that the
primary um um concern of the community
college system and the university system
was in terms of the remedies and that
has been um addressed in this bill um uh
with guard rails on the amount of
awards uh so I think that uh um that uh
is a step forward and making this bill
palatable to all further discussion
representative
Miler thank you Mr chairman I'm going be
voting no on this uh we have we've dealt
with this in this committee several
times
uh we have seen the uh National reigning
from fire uh dealing with free speech
fire is a group that basically looks at
free speech on campus across the country
we have looked at uh their review of
this thing this topic and the university
system has gone from you need
Improvement to ranking one or two in the
country I think the institutions have
done a a a good job
in adjusting their system to make sure
that there is in fact uh free speech on
campus and that this bill is not needed
and it does not recognize what schools
what the colleges have done to try to
address this issue so I don't think this
bill is needed thank you further
discussion representative what
luno sure thank you very much Mr chair
so so while while we just heard um
representative cordelli suggests that
this bill is now palatable um it is
certainly not palatable to um to the
community college system it's not
palatable to the uh the universities in
the University system of New Hampshire
it's not palatable to me I'm certainly
going to be voting voting against the
ought to pass and U and uh for example
one of the things that I find not only
unpalatable but um but but just
completely objectionable and
discriminatory is um is the fact that um
that under the in the freedom of
Association section in this bill that uh
that the um that the bill would uh would
require the uh you know States colleges
and universities to support student
organizations um or not deny support for
a student organization based on any
religious political or IDE
ideological um benefit and privilege uh
incl and it would include the
requirement that um that those
organizations can uh can discriminate uh
against uh against student members so so
uh just the fact that you've got you've
got something here that's that's
blatantly discriminatory uh I I I think
that's unacceptable for New Hampshire
and uh and I'm going to vote against
it represent
Woodcock thank you chairman L um I just
want to I I've read the
information heard the testimony I just
want to follow up on the I didn't hear
what representative I may have
misunderstood what representative Bela
said but the the Attorney General in
their statement to us all um indicated
they weren't taking a position but they
had severe
reservations um if I may just read that
one line if it's okay with you Mr chair
yes um a concern arise with the fact
that the proposed legislation does not
consider the application of all the
harassment laws yet the new definitional
harassment contained in the proposed
legislation raises questions of whether
campus police could enforce the state
criminal harassment laws on campus or
whether institutions of High Learning
could sanction groups that may engage in
criminal harassment um so I don't I
don't read that as a as a host of
support from the Attorney General's
office uh on on the Bill and as as
representative luno indicated both the
the fouryear institution the UNA and the
community col system both testified to
be more difficult for them to give a
fair open uh program and they have they
have already policies in place that
allow this to happen in a regular basis
without much without much issue so I I
also will not be uh supporting this I
don't think it's in the best interest of
the community college system or the
students that go there thank you Mr
chair you're welcome uh representative
Donald thank you Mr chair I won't belor
the issue too much further because I do
support this bill and I believe
representative Belcher noted a lot of
the reasons why but some of the reasons
that were not covered is the fact that
this addresses the issue of a heckler's
veto which is when someone else acts
inappropriately at a student event and
the organization is discriminated
against for no fault of their own as
well of the issue of free speech zones
where free speech is limited to specific
zones on campus which could be the back
corner of the parking lot practically
off campus but not allowed and
everywhere else I'd also like to mention
since fire which is a foundation for
individual rights and expression was
mentioned that they give the University
of New Hampshire a
72% which that might be better than
other
institutions but that's a c I wouldn't
say that's a standard to say that the
school is doing as well as they could
and not not to say that they're not
trying but I think this bill is
necessary at this time for that reason
especially so thank you further
discussion represent
leus yes I two comments one also based
on fire fire bases their ratings based
on the school's policy not on how well
the school um follows their policy I had
that discussion with them
earlier
um and the other part had to do with
freedom of Association if somebody tells
you who you have to associate with that
is not freedom of Association freedom of
Association is when you get to choose
who you associate with and as an example
if the the young
Democrats young students for de the
Democrat Party happen to be in the
minority on a college
campus and the Republicans decided they
wanted to come in and all join and come
the head of the the UN the organization
and decide what way it's going to go I
don't think that would be appropriate
and so that it would be the case I think
for any
small
organization that did not necessarily
follow what the majority of that school
students followed they would not in
effect basically be able to have an
organization because anybody could come
and and usurp it and so for those two
parts of free association I very much
support this Bill thank you further
discussion representative pel thank you
Mr chair um I just want to address um
representative woodcock's concerns
because he was speaking to an email from
January 8th I believe um from director
lock from the Attorney General's office
and yesterday we received two emails one
um both were addressed to the entire
house education committee one from um
the sponsor of the bill where he thanks
director lock for working with him and
finding the correct language and States
I'm happy to hear that house bill 1305
as amended by um 0654 no longer raises
concerns with the Attorney General's
office and in response director lock
says thank you for um thank you for
sending this along and the work that was
done on this I appreciate it and the
amendment does address the concerns
about the enforcement of criminal
laws thank you further discussion
representative cordelli and then
representa
luno uh thank you I I think that the uh
freedom of
expression uh and Association freedom of
Association uh 188 j3 section of the
bill uh is one of the most
important um and in terms of uh
Association um the courts have ruled
that um religious organizations cannot
be discriminated against on campus um
and um it was cited by uh the First
Amendment partnership multiple uh court
cases Supreme Court cases including
Healey versus James
1972 Whitmer versus Vincent 1981 and
Rosenberger versus University of
Virginia
1995 all protect uh um uh associations
wanting to organize on campus that they
can't be denied um access to facilities
they can't be denied um uh activity fees
uh Etc so I think that this section of
the bill is um one of the most important
and we had heard testimony uh dating
back to last year from associations that
had um a problem organizing on campuses
um in this
state represent luno thanks very much
yeah I just don't think um um families
that pay uh pay tuition at uh UNH nor
the taxpayers who support um UNH the
community colleges and the state
universities should uh should
necessarily be on the hook to uh to
provide uh meeting space as well as
funding for extremist groups like
neo-nazis white SU
white supremacists anti-semitic
organizations and the like and uh those
groups are going to exist U but they
don't need to exist as recognized
student groups at the cost to taxpayers
and families that pay tuition and so I'm
going to vote along with I think the
vast majority of granite Staters which
find these groups to be horrific and
should not be operating with uh with
taxpayer or public money thank you
further discussion from the committee
represent leus
part of the whole point of freedom of
speech
is it's free for every person regardless
of their opinion and how obnoxious it is
just because you think an opinion is
obnoxious that other person should not
be kept from making it that's part of
free speech we have to put up sometimes
with things that we don't
like further discussion
not seeing any hands uh Madam clerk
would you please call the role this is
on uh the bill
135 otpa and the A is for 0654
H VI chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Terry yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
Donald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative Miler
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no representative Luna no
representative Heath no Representative
wock no representative Hall no
representative Priest No Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
chairman lad yes 10 y 10 motion what's
your
motion we have a motion made by
represent Myer itl is there a
second represent Luna makes the second
further
discussion represent miler
represent luno no further discussion
from the committee not seeing any Madam
clerk when you're ready Vice chairman
cordelli no Representative leus no
representative Terry no representative
Belcher no representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Pell no representative cello no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Heath yes representative
yes representative Hall yes
representative priest yes representative
cascaden yes representative Damon yes
chairman lad no 10 y 10
NS surprise surprise I'll
do okay uh so the itl Motions made by we
you'll be doing that represent Lun will
be doing
that and repon beler otpa thank you
uh jumping back up to the top we're
going to go to HB
1311 District collection development and
reconsideration policies I
look are you ready yes on the
page I looked to representative Cordell
for a
motion Mr chairman I move that this bill
be
ital is there a
second second repr Le is
seconds so we have a motion on the table
on before us it's HB 1311 is itl made by
represent cordello and second by
represent leus represent cordello do you
have anything to say on it yes Mr chair
um so this bill has to do with
collection development
policies uh
and my main problem with this bill is
the criteria
predominantly puts forth for those
policies and we've all heard obviously
don't judge a book by its
cover well I feel like what this bill
does is is worse than that it it judges
books by the identity of the author or
the
characters and um so this is what I take
issue with and I I was thinking about
this last night sort of I always try to
come up with sort of concrete example
and uh in this list one of the
categories is uh just to make my example
um physical disability um imagine if you
would some book that was written by a
blind person and the entire book was
just a riously obscene and just a book
that anyone would just completely think
would not be suitable in a library
um a parent would not be able to bring
this book forth as one to
be uh reconsidered because you could
pull up this identity of the author and
therefore you know the the it's not so
much that you would judge the content of
the book but the person who wrote it or
the characters in it so
um I'll let other people talk I just
wanted to bring up this is my main
problem with the bill uh and of course
words of Martin Luther King were going
through my head and as I say this last
Point you'll see I'm paraphrasing him a
bit that books and Library material
should not be judged by the identity of
their author or the characters but by
the content of their pages I know that
this bill was mentioned several times
last week as some sort of solution to
this problem uh when we were you know
talking about
1419 and I don't see this as a a
solution at all to uh this problem of
materials and and what books should be
put into our
libraries thank you m thank you very
much further discussion representative
Tanner thank you um yes it it was
mentioned uh with the last bill that we
had and this this bill offers um I
believe a way to
keep local control uh Community
standards of local areas and put things
in context what we heard last
week in rep's Hall was not in
context and um I think this is a wellth
thought out bill it it sets up a a
procedure a policy procedure uh it sets
up um people representative from the
community and the school uh to review
materials in the total context of the
material rather than pull out one or two
paragraphs um obviously no one wants
obscene material uh but obscene material
has to be defined and this policy gives
a PO a way for the community to be
involved in uh reviewing uh
materials further discussion
representative
beler thank you Mr chair
so to me this bill takes the concept of
non-discrimination and totally flips it
upside down children have the right to
be free from abuse yet instead of
seeking to protect children from injury
inflicted by age inappropriate content
this bill would actually seek to protect
the author of the content who is likely
not even a resident of this state from
having their book removed based on their
identity in other words there's no limit
to the obscenely harmful nature of a
book given to minors if the author
happens to claim a certain protected
identity if we use this logic
universally a handgun could be handed to
a child if it were assembled by a
pansexual furry and we could not demand
it be removed for fear of discrimination
against the
assembler the expenditure of public
funds to on literature particularly for
minors must not be predicated on the
identity visions of the author it must
be predicated on the appropriateness of
the content for the book with no regard
for the identity status of anyone
involved because that itself would be
discriminatory thank you further
discussion represent leus then represent
Miler another aspect of this such policy
shall further State the material shall
not be prescribed on the basis of
viewpoint
and if the Viewpoint is that children
should be sexual objects for
adults we would not be able to
discriminate we would not be able to
remove that because that's a
Viewpoint and I think that can be very
dangerous represent
Miler thank you Mr
chair I'm disappointed in this it motion
um
frankly um based upon uh the scene that
was in the uh chamber last week I was
hoping that this would provide an
opportunity for uh common sense to begin
to look at policies that govern what's
in libraries this is the bipartisan bill
that's being presented to us it is uh
been vetted uh through the library
Librarians Etc and um I think this is a
common sense approach uh to looking at
standards that are local uh to deal with
issues uh and I'm again I'm just I'm
disappointed that we can't as a
committee come together in trying to far
it out exactly how we can begin to look
at uh literature Etc that has a kind of
a a community standard that's created by
the committee that's it's recommended
here so I'm I'm I'm sorry I just just
I'm just disappointed that we can't come
to some conclusion on this thank you Mr
chair represent cordelli um thank you um
just in talking about context and so
forth um last week the um uh situation
that was just described uh um on the
house floor um uh complete um materials
could have been read not just excerpts
but um some didn't want us to even hear
the excerpt
let alone the full material that is
present in um schools including middle
schools and uh I'm not sure about
elementary schools um in this state um I
don't think that this bill um
advances um what we have heard we don't
want obscene materials being made
available um to students I don't think
this bill
uh advances that cost or that goal um in
that as we've heard um an author's um
age sex uh sexual orientation um uh is
involved but I'd also point out that
this is not just books this is
applications interactive applications in
software by definition and we have had
testimony about these interactive
applications some of which provide links
for students
possibly middle school students to
communicate with some of these authors
um who are talking about um
um applications that match up um
individuals uh for the purpose of sex um
I don't think that that um is something
we want in our schools uh but this would
seem to say no you have to allow that
otherwise it would be
discrimination so uh I think that this
um in some ways is um uh dangerous
legislation further discussion
representative
Woodcock thank you
uh thank you represent live first off I
take exception
to representative Cordelia using this
bill is any way to gu a support for that
obnoxious andar Place presentation on
the floor I would was responding to if I
just speaking please thank you um
there's no way this comes close to that
activity that being said uh represent
lad uh at the hearing uh we had received
the technical advisory from uh the
Department of Education uh dated May 12
2023 at that hearing I asked if you
would you Rec you request from them uh
the preview the
2017 uh technical advisory the pre seed
this one and I don't we haven't received
that yet and I don't know if if you
happen to have a chance to do that or
you put it in or they didn't do it or
there was one here and disappeared we
did get a report back from them and that
was a temporary technical advisory as
you recall that it was quickly changed
if if we're on the same page here that
was different bill that's another bill
that's another bill that was dealing
with the
rules2 people question because it came
all very quickly out it was 2017 the
fa got that no okay um thank you I would
recall
what page and I
know background
so but the thing
that can't out my mind when R speaking
he that students have the right to see
themselves in live
reading uh all this bill does is start
the first step for local school boards
to start processing so everybody has
policiy uh that govern media collections
which is I think something we all want
no one wants as representative T just
said no one wants to see a SE material
in the school we want to see something
this is this is the perfect bypass
opportunity to start that process to
have school board do that I
think I I've got a question has anybody
on the committee seen a boiler plate
policy that's been put together by the
New Hampshire school boards Association
relative to how uh books in library may
be reconsidered where they stay on the
shelves or they're taken off the shelves
within a certain period of the the
request um is there such a policy out
there representative
cascaden if I may yes to your
question but may I speak yes yes okay
yes um this bill actually
um provides more local control and don't
you want less government intervention it
also complements the policy of
collection development policies for
school library media centers for
essential curriculum development
procedures for selection of materials
selection criteria for SEL uh for
selection selection of
non-print materials selection of print
materials procedures to be followed for
chall
materials I think that when it gets down
to the nitty-gritty of determining
appropriateness it's time for a parent
to take responsibility for
that um links that are available to
sex can be attained through the home
that's all I have to say so in in
response to my question yes were those
technical advisories or boilerplate
policies issued by the school boards
Association are actually School Board
adopted policies that were modeled after
the sample School Board Association
policies thank you Mr chair if I may
representer when when U Mr Christina was
in in his
testimony uh during the uh 129 hearing
he did indicate that they do have those
policies and there is a recodification
process that they use so to answer I
think to answer your qu I don't those
policies haven't been presented to the
committee uh but the representative of
the school boards Association was clear
that they do have policies that try to
address this issue and this bill would
basically complement those
policies then my followup question was
why do we need this bill if we have
policies already out there correct they
fall under the K section if you look at
any public school district that has
their online policies they are in the K
section so
KC's um
and KC D- RS are the actual
procedures represent leus do you have
your hand
up yes thank
you the part of this that says for those
schools who might not have a policy that
they need to have a policy and what that
PO you know and what that policy needs
to cover Etc that's great and if this
just did that that would be great the
problem is it has these exceptions and
for me the Viewpoint
exception is a killer because there are
people who believe that pedophilia is a
good thing and I don't want books to
be um pushing that and not be able to be
disallowed because that's a
Viewpoint and so to me that's the killer
if you just said every school has to
have a policy the policy has to cover
these things I'm all for that I think
that would be good that's what I was
hoping this bill was and then when I saw
the exceptions I'm like why did they
have to poison the bill why couldn't
they just leave it as come up with a
policy thank you further discussion on
represent McDonald thank you Mr chair
I'd like to bring it back to something
representative Woodcock mentioned and
I'm glad he mentioned the fact that the
prime sponsor stated the right to
representation CU that's something that
stood out to me during the hearing as
well right to representation in school
libraries and I pressed the prime
sponsor a little bit too and he added
right to see all different types of
people found in New Hampshire in school
libraries all different types and if we
believe that every person is different
and unique that's about 1.4 million
people in the state of New Hampshire and
does that mean that we should have 1.4
million books at least in each School
library and to build accommodating
spaces to house these books and if that
is a stated intent of this bill then why
is there not a fiscal note attached to
this and couldn't you even see that as
an unfunded mandate I just have a lot of
questions with this bill so I cannot
support it thank you further discussion
on on the bill yes representative per
yes I have a concern with um line 16
where um it states that we a policy will
be be established um by which parents
and permanent Guardians May submit a
request for consideration to the school
superintendent and principal and we're
talking about um establishing Community
standards but this process stops with
the superintendent or the principal and
doesn't even get it to the school board
where it would see the light of day and
a true Community standard could be
established further
discussion not seeing any further hands
up uh for a discussion Madam
clerk the motion was put forward by as
an
itl for HB
1311 and this is a bill relative to um
the collection and development and
reconsideration policies uh for uh
School
collections nice go ahead Vice chairman
cordelli yes representative leus yes
representative Terry yes representative
beler yes representative dry
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble representative Pell
yes representative cor yell yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
representative Luna no representative
Heath no Representative wock no
representative Hall no representative
Priest No Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad yes
10 y 10 y represent
miler to OTP please uh motion put forth
of OTP is there a second represent
Tanner second
yep you got the sheet the sheet okay so
a mtion a motion to OTP made by
represent Miler and second by
representative Tanner represent Miler I
think open represent
Tanner further discussion from the
committee don't see any Madam clerk call
the role please Vice chairman
cordelli no Representative leus no
representative Terry no Representative
beler no representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble Representative pel
no representative Corell no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative lunell yes representative
Heath representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
priest yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
10 a 10 days
Tanner okay so represent Tanner does
the report for OTP and representative
who put that
for yeah Arlene you've got the all right
it is everybody needing a moment to
stand up or at least get a little lunch
no we will keep
moving
okay looking at the sheet you had master
sheet
here
yes
10 okay okay we are going to move
forward with a couple more bills before
lunch
time so we're jumping down to uh
1594 establishing an annual review for
EFA
eligibility
[Music]
who do we have for that one I'm not
going to get into long debate on oh no
so folks I think we we we know where
we're going on this bill
so let's just cut to the chase here
representative pel you recommended or
recognize for a motion yes I move in
expedient to legislate on House Bill
1594 is there
second represent beler seconds
representative Pell's motion of itl on
1594 representative Pell yes thank you
Mr chair um this bill would require
means testing for Education Freedom
account recipients in years subsequent
to the initial qualifying period And if
a family no longer qualifies a student
might be forced to return to an
educational system that was not meeting
their needs the purpose of the
educational Freedom account program is
to to encourage parents to seek
educational opportunities that maximize
their child's potential this bill would
disincentivize parents from advancing in
their occupations or income level
because a modest wage increase of $1 per
hour could eliminate their child from
the program knowing that such a slight
increase would prohibit future funding
could be a discouraging to access to
accessing the successful program
education Freedom accounts are currently
be being utilized by 3% of qualifying
students demonstrating
slow controlled growth it would be
unfair to eliminate funding for students
thriving in an academic
setting further
discussion represent
Miler well I put for thank you Mr chair
I put for this
bill and I provided to the
committee uh and an analysis of those
bills that have poverty related issues
within our stfe budget this is the only
B bill that this is the only program
that doesn't have that kind of uh uh
recertification every year uh and it
just only seems fair to me that you know
we're not dealing with uh a small budget
here we're dealing with millions of
dollars and it only seems right from a
taxpayer standpoint that have some sense
of recertification of what who should
qualify notwithstanding what
representing pattern El I understand
that but the point is is that if uh at
this point in time if a person starts in
the program and they're making uh
$440,000 a year and over five or six
years they're now up beyond that that
350% it only seems right to me from a
from a taxpayer standpoint that there
ought to be some accountability of who
qualifies here this should not be an
open-ended system here there ought to be
some sense of guide guard rails now we
have advanced several guard rails here
you're going to see one in just a minute
to provide some sense of accountability
of this particular program and I frankly
I'm surprised at the for those who are
concerned about how we spend money in
this state that there's not some more
recognition of the need to have some
kind of guard RS at some point in time
they're going to be there and this is
just a I believe it's a common sense
approach to saying you know if you've
got just like you have snap just like
you have other poverty programs that
there ought to be a recertification here
it's to me it's a it's a simple analysis
of what we need to provide some sense of
guard rails for this particular
program thank you further discussion
representa
leus first off we're talking about
education and we're talking about the
money that's provided by the state to
educate the kids in the state which is a
different thing um if you have money for
food coming from the state and then you
have enough money you provide food for
your family but you can't keep providing
necessarily the education that your kid
is at so if your your um income pops
around which some people do then you're
jerking the kid around okay you can be
in you can go to the school that's
working for you okay this year now you
can't you got to go back to the public
school that wasn't working for you where
you were being bullied and you weren't
getting the services you needed oh but
this year you can go back and that is
not not fair to the kids and it's the
kids and the education of the kids we're
talking about here and that's why that
was put in to begin with was to make
sure kids weren't being messed around
and shuffled from school to school so
they had some stability thank you thank
you very much further discussion
representative Woodcock and then
representative
Hall thank you represent Hall thank you
um first of all this program is an
eligibility cap program it's not
Universal it was voted down it's
eligibility and the idea that these kids
are going to be jerked around and
they're going to be sent back to public
school clearly these kids were in
private school to start with the
majority of them so to suggest that
they're going to all of a sudden all go
back to public school forced back to
public school I think is a total fallacy
thank you you're welcome represent
belshire thank you Mr chair I just want
to look at the cost of this and how
we're looking at the cost of this bill
for a moment because as of right now an
educational student educational Freedom
account student receives 4500 a year
which is roughly a quarter of the
average cost of sending a child to
public school now a parent is much more
likely to receive a modest income
increase than a significant income
increase what that means is there is a
really good chance that the net effect
of this bill is more students going back
to public school and increased cost to
the taxpayer as they move from freedom
accounts back to their Public School
meaning this bill at the end of the day
is punitive to both students and the
taxpayer thank you further discussion
from the
committee yeah not not not to belor this
conversation but 87% of the kids are
already in private schools when they get
their
vouchers the number of whatever the term
is of those who the switchers who go
from public schools to private schools
is marginal so to think that they're
going to go back to Public Schools when
they're already in it and receiving the
voucher to me it's a full hearty
argument any further represent
leus in the very first weeks of the
program the numbers were small for
switchers by the time the program was
really up and running by like November
it was 45%
45% I'm not sure what it is right now
but that was even already considering
that a number of those kids had gone to
public school they just hadn't gone to
public school the year before well what
was the year before it was covid a lot
of public schools were closed kids had
already switched to private schools just
so they could go to school and private
schools had discounts for them so they
could afford that discount they couldn't
necessarily afford the full
amount but they were in public school
before that but the switchers counts
just those coming immediately not those
who were already in public school and
switched for covid so the timing of this
makes all of those
statistics messed up thank
you representative pel yes thank you um
two points first of
all if these children were already in
private schools and they're um accessing
the education Freedom Accounts at the
350%
rate those families are sacrificing and
struggling already significantly we are
helping those families out that to and
to that point we like to talk about
feeding these kids and this has been
compared to snap and tanif programs and
the the um sunset provision if your
income rises above the qualifications
for the those um for those programs
however if we want to talk about feeding
kids maybe the education Freedom account
program is what makes the difference in
a family being able to feed their
children good food or better
food further discussion represent you I
I see your red light on I'm sorry turn
not seeing any further discussion Madam
clerk we're ready to call the
rooll
can you the bill that we're discussing
is uh establishing an annual review and
qualification to determine eligibility
to participate in the education Freedom
accounts program the motion is
OTP itl itl excuse me itl excuse me yeah
itl Vice chairman cordelli yes represent
leus yes representative Terry
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no representative Luna no
representative he no representative WKA
no representative Hall no representative
Priest No Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad yes
ten 10 n represent
Miler i' move to on to pass second
there's a motion made by represent miler
OTP second by representative
luno on HP 1594 further discussion from
the maker of the motion let's move to
vote please represent luno let's go any
discussion from the committee Madam
clerk Vice chairman cordelli
no Representative leus no representative
Terry no Representative beler no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative Pell no Representative
corello no representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Heath yes
representative
wock yes representative Hall yes
representative priest yes representative
cascaden yes representative Damon yes
chairman lad no 10 a 10
a okay who's going to do the report
represent Miler and
okay next bill we're taking up 1512 HP
1512 limiting EF funding to budgeted
amounts so let's turn to
we have making a motion here represent
cordelli you recognize for a motion uh
thank you Mr chair I move
itl is there a second to the
itl represent leus uh represent cordelli
uh has moved itl on 1512 second by
represent lez represent cordelli uh
thank you Mr chairman
um this um Bill takes a little different
approach we we know we have an income
cap on the uh education Freedom account
bill this puts a budget cap on the total
program um it limits the number of
students um who can participate in the
program even if they uh meet the family
income cap um
requirement um what happens to those
students um they are
trapped in a education environment that
is not meeting their
needs um that is not the goal of this
program and I don't think of Education
in general um and that uh I think uh
public education is about educating the
public and uh that's what our focus
should be making sure that every every
child has the ability to uh get get the
education that meets their uh individual
needs um uh I can remember hearing ads
on the radio from uh Nea about each
child is unique and learns
differently um I believe that uh I agree
with Nea on that point and I don't think
that capping this program based on an
arbitrary number when is the way we want
to go especially when the education uh
trust fund is set up so that um if funds
are needed there's automatically a
warrant drawn for more funds from from
the general fund um and as we heard in
the last bill I think from
representative petel it's something like
3% of the eligible uh children um in the
state are taking advantage of this so to
think that there is um some year down
the road where there's going to be a a
mass Exodus of students from the public
school system um well it's not going to
be from the EFA program but it's going
to be because of the as we've seen over
the past two decades and we'll continue
continue to see for the next decade the
mass Exodus is due to
demographics um so I think that capping
this program to a arbitrary budgeted
amount um is really uh impacting uh not
our only our children's uh education but
um our future as well because we know
children are our
future further discussion represent
leus I don't believe the C that we cap
the
amount that Charter Public School Kids
how much how many kids can go to those
and that is an
alternative educational program program
that the state
provides for different learning styles
Etc and this is just
another different alternative
educational opportunity for kids with
different learning styles and I don't
think we should cap it
either I got a question for anybody on
the committee here I'm I'm looking at
this expense of $19.8 million per year
of the banum but in fact we're
allocating for that bium $ 39.6
million with the wording here could we
spend in the first year of the banum $25
million or would we have to stick to the
19 but allocated for that bium is $9.6
million this is a question that as a
matter of interpretation is brought up
in the fiscal note that we should be
very cautious
of represent miler all right thank you
Mr chair let me try to to be reasonable
again I mean I mean seriously I mean
this is this is a this is a new
program it's been in in place about
three years each year it's gone over
budget
right well from from a fiscal
conservative
standpoint I would appeal to those of
you that are fiscally
conservative to at least recognize that
there are some limits now let's say you
go over the budget no problem no problem
here you come back to the fiscal
committee and say ask for some more
money it happens all the
time all this is saying is that well
let's have some kind of review if in
fact you reach that budget limit that's
all it's saying it's not trying to not
to deny
children it's basically saying go back
to the fiscal committee give us another
projection of how much you think you
might
need it's a simple concept
folks you may disagree with it but there
should be some oversight by somebody in
this
state to say where are we with I don't
know about your budget but I on a
monthly basis I say where are we with
our budget are we over it are we under
it do we need to make some
modifications and this case the
modifications would come from the fiscal
committee easy peasy
here further comments representative
petam would it be a good fiscally
conservative conversation to have to
consider eliminating the phaseout grants
to the public schools that come along
with the education Freedom
accounts represent
whitcock thank you Mr chair um one of
the things we talk about is is the the
the uh program how educationally solid
is and based and and I'm just looking at
the the uh print
out some of the expenses because we
don't want to deny any education here
Alex shoe stoer American Eagle Breezy
teas Bootleggers Brillion Co Factory
designer shoes discount dance darling's
clothing
French toast famous footb Gap Global
sportsware Joes King store Len Macy's
Mar parel Old Navy New Balance red brick
clothing ship Masters silver gr chees
sketches Target TJ
Maxx so at some point there has to be
some balance here we talking about got
to educate the kids educate the kids
$5,000 we're up to 30 $30 million right
now and that's a long rip that's just
one list came from the from the
organization uh of some of these
expenses so I mean when we think about
what we using for educational money I
think there has to be some some because
you sure wouldn't do that with your
money at your home thank you thank you
very much representative Belcher thank
you Mr chair and I'll be the first one
to admit that usually when we do things
in politics name bills and whatnot you
usually look to the opposite of what
it's called to learn what it does but I
think this one's a bit of an exception
the education Freedom account actually
gives parents the freedom to choose what
they're going to do when you give people
Freedom you don't know what they're
going to do it's kind of up in the air
so it would be impossible to foretell
the budget for a program based on
freedom so I have to say if if you pass
this bill you you might as well get the
F out because it's no longer a freedom
account further discussion
representative cascaden um just for
clarify ification um for those who don't
know um I mean education Freedom
accounts were not around when I was a
school principal and then when I was a
superintendent they came around but you
need to know because you obviously don't
know that with or without education
Freedom accounts parents always had
choice
always I I sometimes told parent move to
the next town if you don't like it
or write me a note in home school but if
there was any other type of school or
program or any type of educational
environment the parent has the choice
and always did so please stop referring
as education Freedom accounts which is
public dollars for private use as losing
parent choice because they're not losing
it they've always had it it's just who
pays for it
representative perinel yes thank
you um representative cascaden did you
say that Parents Choice was that they
had to move to attend a different
school do you want me answer represent
kcan if you want to we we only had one
school in our district and if parents
didn't like the rules and they wanted to
change the rules and say well maybe
you'd be better served in another town
followup yes so are you saying there
constrained by the zip code in which
they live they can't you couldn't
tuition them out to a school that would
suit their needs better depends on the
situation always of tuition to other
Public Schools but parents have the
choice as the ultimate bottom
line representative cordelli thank you I
would just say that U I don't think that
all parents have a choice um in effect
we have uh ZIP code
discrimination
um
um some parents with financial means can
certainly move to a different uh
neighborhood where maybe there is a a
better performing school with better
proficiency rates um uh I read a book um
called redlining that showed a number of
major cities um Chicago Los Angeles and
it was very interesting to look at the
red line
um of districts for bank loans that used
to be in effect and how School District
boundaries matched with those redlining
districts it was fascinating to look at
um and uh in that same book there was a
story um about the author's brother
wanted to move to uh Chicago and looked
at found a beautiful home on the north
side of North Avenue in
Chicago but then discovered the
proficiency rates were in the
30%
range went to the other side of North
Avenue where there was a a low
performing
school
um excuse me it was the other way around
he found a low performing School a house
that he loved went to the other side of
the U North Avenue and where there was
um uh a better performing school but the
house was a quarter of a million dollars
more and it wasn't even one that they
really like
but had to move or select the higher
priced home in order to get a free and
appropriate
education um sure some parents can um
elect a homeschool but not all parents
that does not fit with every every
parent situation a single mother is
going to have a hard time um uh
homeschooling so um I uh I don't agree
with that argument um in the least um
and I think that um education Freedom
accounts um are well-named
and try to
address the um maybe the shortcomings in
the current system in terms of zip code
discrimination but also in terms of uh
performance of some
schools representative Miler yeah thank
you Mr chair the latter part of this
conversation is very interesting but I
want to bring us back to the
focus focus of this bill is staying
within the budget amount that's all it
is we can have the other conversation
about zip codes and accesss and all that
stuff this bill focuses on do you want
the program to stay within the budget if
you do you You' vote for it knowing full
well that if you go over the budget you
can come back and ask for more
money it's a simple Bill
folks yes or
no further discussion represent
leus well given that we went over over
budget uh the last few years I would say
that we do a terrible job of budgeting
for a highly popular program and perhaps
we should budget more money
great further discussion representa
Damon reflecting on representative lakus
remarks yes we should do a better job of
budgeting and this is to that end it
would increase transparency on the cost
of the education Freedom account
program I frankly do not understand in a
time
when all of my constituents and I would
expect most people's constituents are
very concerned about the way the state
is spending money and what their taxes
are why wouldn't we want to be
transparent set the limit have to come
back and ask fiscal for more money if
that were needed I fully support this
bill so I I've got a question for every
if if we're capping here on this program
should we be capping our Public School
hey we've already reached our limit in
the public school so you're going to
have to go find another school elsewhere
to go to school we actually do we do
based on the prior year number no I'm
not talking about that I'm talking about
the student that arrives at the doors is
that student
rejected never never never never so why
should a student be rejected from this
program as
well represent
Damon thank you
because public schools are a
constitutional requirement and they
educate all students and it's not one
size fits
all represent
Woodcock thank you I just want to
respond to the budget question I I agree
with representative Lakers that we've
done a horrible job budgeting the
commissioner of Education gave us the
initial number of
129,000 and that's what we used and we
spent 8
million that's all I mean we start what
the commissioner told us thank you
represent
dry thank you um I because I wanted to
ask how if we went over budget a warrant
would draw money from the education
trust fund if we've taken out the part
that says if regardless of the balance
of funds available in that fund and made
it specifically tied to a number at the
bottom bot for this year a physical
number and for subsequent years an
appropriated number that we don't know
yet represent cordelli um thank you um
the original budget for this
program um was based on the takeup rate
if you will of um uh students in other
states um I think was maybe six states
that had similar programs at that point
um so that's what the uh original budget
was based on but you have to factor in
that this started up after the
pandemic after the pandemic when schools
were closed when parents saw what was
going on through remote learning and
some were not happy so I think it was um
totally um uh understandable that the
takeup rate in New Hampshire might have
been higher than originally projected
because it was coming after the pandemic
and just uh point about the fiscal
committee I remember um maybe five or
six years ago when um uh we got a grant
of $40 million for uh Charter
Schools it had to be accepted by the
fiscal committee before the education
department could do anything with it
well guess what uh one party in the
majority at that point kept tabling
acceptance of that $40 million Federal
grant month after ma month until a new
party became the majority and that
Federal grant was accepted so um you
know relying on the fiscal committee to
say uh yes I think is a dicey
proposition and I can even further go
back in memory and remember when charter
school started here we had $10 million
sitting in a pot to help with lease
costs and all that for
Charters and folks refuse to go to that
pot I can remember that solidly sitting
there in the governor's office talking
about this represent dry yes I dry first
thank you this isn't the qu answer to
the question that I'm asking I'm asking
here if we go over the budget this year
then we're supposed to back to the
fiscal committee to ask for a warrant to
get to go over the budget but the bud
the warrant for that payment shall not
exceed 19,800 th000 so where do we get
the over budget from if we're not
allowed to go beyond that
point repr sen luno thank you Mr chair
and the um the the Democratic majority
on the fisal committee uh back four
years ago when uh when those when the
expanded
uh the charter expansion grants were uh
were were not approved was absolutely
the right thing to do we just saw a
charter go go absolutely insolvent due
to fraud uh after having taken and I
forgot the number I think it's $1.4
million of that of that Federal grant
it's probably in somebody's pocket we
don't know but uh but they went they
went in solement in solement with um uh
after taking um taxpayer money so
without guard rails like this bill does
without guard rails like what the um
like what the uh The Joint um uh fiscal
committe committee is supposed to do
this is the type of stuff that happens
fraud and misuse and unfortunately the
majority in charge right now apparently
is allowing that to happen and uh what
we saw with with the with the the
finance committee when waving on even
taking a look at what uh what expanding
the voucher program would cost state
taxpayers is just endemic of what is um
what is happening under the current
majority thank you I want to clarify
that the the majority did not allow that
to occur the majority when they found
out that this was going on it was
stopped represent
dry okay I'm G to ask for a third time
if we go over the budget this year
they're supposed to be able to ask for a
warrant to cover that but I don't see
that in this line six to line 12 such
warrant for payment shall not exceed
$1,800,000 that's just my
question represent Tanner I'm afraid I'm
not going to answer your question but
I'd like to call for the vote I think
we've beat this to death
is there any further discussion because
the rule state we cannot call a vote
like that if there's further discussion
we're going to have it represent
Woodcock thank you represent lad um I
just wanted to respond to uh
representative Celli's statement not
that I haven't done already a couple
times today um what one more when you
said parents no one was happy with the
schools and they uh went wanted the
uh budgeting for the EA during remote
during the remote
period and Glenn I agree with you I
don't think any parents in New Hampshire
were happy with remote learning during
covid but that was a crisis and no one
the ones I looked on was not happy
that's for sure of looking on that
little screen trying to teach at home so
I I agree with you 100% on that but it
had nothing to do with the EFA going
over budget
further discussion on the bill not
seeing
any we're dealing with HB 152 the motion
for 1512 is to
itl Madam VI Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Terry yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
mcdonal yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative
no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no representative
Luna no representative Heath no
representative W no representative Hall
no representative Priest No
Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad yes
10 y 10 n represent Miler move to
OTP motion made by representative Miler
to OTP and a second from representative
Tanner further
discussion
motion is OTP on
1512 Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative leus no representative
Terry no representative beler
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative
Pell no representative cell no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Heath yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
priest yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman l no
10 y 10
y represent Miler will do the
itl
OTP
and okay so far this morning we've done
one two three four five six seven eight
bills we still have a number there we're
going to have have a a lunch right
now uh several bills we're going to hold
but we still have bills we got we will
be out of here by 3:00
today 3 o'clock so we'll take a lunch
right now and we'll come back here which
the see it's only 20 minutes of
12 is I know that's a stop clock uh
we'll come back at
uh at 1 15 12 120 make it 120 some want
to go out and get
meal
e
know didn't they say something about
blue light or something oh yeah oh she's
checking the
stream I'll check okay wait reps
doing these
um no CU next we don't have
anything
okay
which okay we have three bills which
we're going to be addressing this
afternoon
1671 and
1382 that leaves one two three 4
uh five six bills I believe one two
three four five six
bills for tomorrow which we should be
able to get out of here by noon we're
waiting for amendments and we're waiting
for information to get from the
department and we're meeting with the
Department tomorrow morning early
represent cordellia and I um
so let's get on the first one for right
now that's
1162 that's a bill relative to teaching
discrimination in public schools and
discrimination in public
workplaces
yes
it yeah right with
me okay represent
alus you recognize for a motion I would
like to move itl on 1162 two is our
second represent no no you're you're
you're third she's second
okay repr Cordell second the
motion uh represent leus um made a
motion for itl on 1162 second by
represent cordello represent leus you
recognized as numerous of you have heard
me say before tell stories about about
things that have happened to kids kids
that either I was present for their
response or that were the kids of fellow
Representatives including one rep's
daughter who came home from school upset
and said Mom it's a good thing I'm a
girl otherwise I'd have nothing going
for me and the boy who was afraid that
he would beat up his best friend who was
a girl because all boys were
oppressors and
we heard a lot of those things prior to
this law being
passed I don't hear those now like I did
then I do hear other things that are
more subtle but those straight out
racist all whites are racist all boys
are oppressors I do I have not been
hearing those like I did before this law
was passed so I would hate to see this
repealed and go back to where we were
before further discussion on the bill
represent
forell thank you Mr chair so um when I
read this I was like H this sounds
familiar and the reason being is it's
asking for the repeal of the
anti-discrimination law just like hp61
last year which I was very um opposed to
and my arguments are the same now um
what in the
uh the current law is objectionable I
pointed out when we had the hearing I
asked a question about my big problem
with this is the wording it's really um
disturbing in a way it says basically
you can engage engage in any form of
instruction just that phrase any form of
instruction troubles me greatly all the
guard rails has been taken away and I've
heard anecdotes about uh students uh
coming home and you know uh feeling as
if they they you know Mommy I you know m
a racist you know I could go on with
anecdotes anecdotes prove nothing but um
instruction that makes a child feel that
way should not be acceptable and the
other thing was that teaching uh this
law makes people uh teachers
feel hesitant to teach certain things
and I have been a teacher I taught and I
think bought this up last year um
teaching slave narratives um I never
felt like anything you know I this
anti-discrimination law going into
effect if I was to go back and teach
again nothing would change in the way I
would teach I thought it was ironic that
one of the speakers mentioned tequila
mocking bir that happens to be the book
I selected for the book club I run at my
library I have no problems I have no
concerns about covering that book um I
think the guard rails here
are if you know I don't know what's
objectional about these in in the so why
would we repeal a law then I'll let
other people speak their peace that's
mine thank you you're welcome represent
Tanner thank you um first of all I'd
like to say that uh over my years of
teaching there probably were kids that
went home and um had misconceptions
about what happened in class I remember
one class I I said to one girl that she
was being obstructor that day and uh the
next day her her mother called and was
all upset you know what was I calling
her daughter because she didn't
understand what the word was it's a
teachable moment kids are going to go
home with misconceptions over what
happens in a classroom and if they bring
it to a parent that's a teachable moment
for the parent it's also a time for the
parent to talk about values if it's a
delicate subject and sometimes in health
class we actually had um projects where
kids had to go home or had to talk to
other people uh about certain things so
that they got uh a different view so
that's that's one side of it on the
teaching side of it I've talked to
several teachers who have been called up
on this particular Bill who have been
taken out of an AP class the day before
the AP
exam uh not allowed to prep for her
students because she was under
investigation ation the investigation
proved
unfounded um goes back into that class
and imagine a teacher going back into
the class not knowing who actually was
offended not knowing not being able to
talk if it was a student about what the
teachable moment was and and what the
misunderstanding was knowing that the
rest of the people in the school also
knew that she was under investigation
realizing that this that somebody in the
classroom could actually use it as a as
a ploy or as a as a I don't know
retaliation would be the right point to
put it but let's say they were unhappy
with their grade or something and and
decided to to turn the teacher in we've
heard stories antidotal stories of the
Department of Education actually
instituting challenges within schools um
to say that teachers aren't affected by
this is crazy
um all you have to do is go out there
and talk to the public school uh people
to know how this bill is affecting
particularly social studies teachers but
also other teachers and you know I am
frustrated with the
constant um approach of this this
committee the bills that we're getting
in this committee not the committee
itself but the bills we're getting in
this committee that try to try to put
not just guardrails but jail sales
around teachers about what they can
teach when they can teach and they're
professionals we're professionals we've
been trained and if somebody is
violating something um and I think this
was brought up in one of the
testimonials if somebody's violating
something then they're dealt with on the
local level and they can be dealt with
with the school board um we're not
making laws for one or two antidotal
situations so um I think it's time this
this bill goes into the trash can thank
you further discussion represent
Belcher thank you Mr chair and there's
already been a lot of talk about the the
the school topic here and and what
children are being taught but I want to
look for a moment at the other aspect of
this which is workplace
training uh right now from coast to
coast there are a plethora of lawsuits
ongoing based on these sorts of
anti-racism and other trainings that are
being done and there have been rulings
suggesting that they may be violative of
the Civil Rights Act so by repealing
this and going back to this sort of
thing Not only would I believe it will
be discriminatory but I think it would
be opening us up to a substantial amount
of litigation and possibly millions and
millions of dollars of liability thanks
further discussion representative
Woodcock thank you chairman lad and
welcome back from lunch
uh I have some notes in this paper one
was from my associate used to set to my
left representative Ford and he made the
comment he said we need to teach
complete history is important right now
we're only doing the clipboard use of
history and one of the other parts we
talking about having taught social
studies for a few years one of the other
testimonies we had if you recall we had
a history teacher specialist sitting
there saying to us we can teach the what
when
where but we not this doesn't allow us
to teach the how and the why that what's
critical and and I I have a concern that
we start to minimize what we can teach
because teachers in the profession are
concerned about what they can say and
not say and what dialogue and and
discourse they get and you can tell me
teachers can teach anything they want
the reality is they can't they're
nervous and those Socratic dialogues
that happen in the classroom are gone a
miss or aai or stopped and we're we're
actually short changing our our students
with the law the way we have it right
now thank you Mr chair thank you
represent
McDonald thank you Mr chair if any of
you have been looking at the bulk of
email testimony we have received it
seems that the general public is
confused at least to the Parliamentary
procedure regarding this bill so just a
point of clarification for someone who
may be watching we are talking about an
anti-discrimination law passed in 2021
this bill seeks to repeal that law the
current motion is itl meaning you are
against the bill and in favor of keeping
the status quo the bill as is seems a
bit backward so I just thought
clarification would be needed but thank
you you're welcome rep Miler thank you
Mr chair I want to remind the
committee that we had a teacher shortage
work group that worked for almost two
years we interviewed all kinds of people
dealing with the various issues that are
causing teacher shortage
and one of the
telling testimonies that one day we had
teachers come in and they basically
focused on this
bill they talked about how the ban
Concepts was in fact negatively
impacting their freedom to
teach and as a matter of fact part of
the recommendations of that committee
recommendation six of that committee was
to deal with this bill because it was
putting a a part
in carpet if you may or blanket over how
they teach there's vagueness in the
language and that vagueness in the
language basically provides an
uncertainty of what I can and can't say
in the
classroom and so I would encourage the
committee here to vote against the itl
so that an alternative motion can be
made further comments from the committee
represent
cordelli uh thank you uh I would just
point out um in uh section 2 line 9 uh
a29 um is basically right to freedom
from discrimination in public work
places and
education
so Public Work
places will be open to discrimination
this this um section even says nothing
shall be construed to limit sensitivity
training in the workplace that's
gone um and this section also says um
RS a29 through
834 and the subdivision heading
preceding them
relative I I'm not sure what is it the
immediate subsection why isn't the
subsection named they're naming five
subsections but they're saying
subsections above that are to be
repealed as well I I don't understand
what the intent there
is further
discussion not seeing any uh Madam
clerk we have a motion on before us here
on HB
1162 this is relative to teaching
discrimination public schools and
discrimination public workplaces the
motion is
itl byce chman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Terry representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
Cordell yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no Representative luno no
representative Heath no representative
Woodcock no representative Hall no
representative Priest No Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
German lad yes ten 10 represent Miler
move to
I no move to OTP
take and the second was made by
represent Tanner so we have a motion on
before us here uh from made by represent
Miler and second by represented Tanner
to OTP HB
1162 further discussion from the maker
of the motion none thank you from the
second
any further discussion from the
committee not seeing any Madam clerk
please call the rule Place chairman
cordelli no Representative leus no
representative Terry no Representative
beler no representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Pell no representative Coro no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes representative wuka yes
representative Hall yes representative
priest yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
10 y 10 days do
okay
okay got all together there okay good
okay uh the next bill which is on the
docket for this afternoon is HB
1671 school officials right of action
for d es for false accusations
okay we had an amendment there just
opening up to discussion right now
before we go any further um represent
Tanner that was your Amendment and we've
heard from representa cordelli that it's
not your main to the main Bill
itself um represent cordellia can you if
I might um yes I W wrote to uh uh the
clerk and the speaker on February 12th
and uh got a reply from the chief of
staff
on um February 12th uh stating the
speaker in consultation with the house
clerk has determined that the amendment
0499 H is non
gerain so with with
that um we can't take that up today
yes this if it was part of the bill and
it was a new
introduction um on what grounds would
they have ruled it non
gerain is there a ruling or they just
say
no the I read you the email um they read
that they sent me um I think that um you
know one one consideration is uh the
amendment is dealing with an entirely
different section of
statute
and and that is what oftentimes bills or
amendments are ruled non Germain when
they reference a totally different
section of statutory
law
well un fortunately or unfortunately
either way you want to take this is the
decision's been made by the speaker
and it's been ruled not
gerain so I'm not going to allow it to
come forward on the bill
1671 and we'll deal with the bill as
introduced representative Woodcock thank
you just a couple questions I may on uh
procedure protocol um Mr chair can can
you tell me when that uh the date of
that
inquiry uh on the germanness of that
amendment was
made as I read uh it was February 12th
and was the sponsor of the M fall Please
Mr
cheer go ahead thank you was the sponsor
of the bill notifi that as a courtesy uh
no and who initiated if I who initiated
the request I
did and one more if I when did did you
receive the re response February 12th 8
days
ago today is 20th simple math even
Public School the 20 okay so going going
back to that
point just a question since then did you
have you notified the representative
Tanner is or the represent Woodcock this
L of questioning is not referencing the
amendment the amendment has been ruled
non gerain I wasn't I was exactly
referencing questioning that as a curent
y I would think procedural courtesy if
you're going to do that courtesies work
both
ways I I think we've had our discussion
right
here I I I think Mr
chair that there is a protocol here and
that is when the vice chair of the
committee gets information about a
particular bill that's not ger main it
would seem to me it would be at least a
s I don't know what the Mason's rule
says about this but it would seem to me
a sense of courtesy to at least let the
uh maker the the prime sponsor of the
bill the of the amendment to not notify
them of the status of that so that a
particular if there's a a change that
needs to make there is time to be able
to do that so I think it's totally
inappropriate to withhold that
information without sharing that uh with
the Prime with the prime sponsor of the
M and I would hope in the future that
that protocol would be uh maintained by
the uh leadership of this committee and
I believe last year um on the day of the
exec session I had two bills with
amendments ruled n
Germain okay here Mr chair would it be
appropriate for us to hold this bill so
that now that we have this
information that the um uh maker of the
amendment would have time to basically
address this new information that's just
come before us before we're supposed to
vote on this
bill I would recommend that we hold it
so she can have at least have a chance
to deal with this new information that's
just come
forth I I see no problem with that
request we will hold this bill and bring
the bill up for full committee
discussion
tomorrow the last bill we're going to be
dealing with
today is
1382 we could all turn to 1382 that is a
bill that deals with the military
Compact and it references students that
are special
education
yeah
sort like an artillery round you bracket
it and you'll find your page
eventually
okay
okay who do we have here for making that
motion okay I I'll hand the gavl over to
represent cordelli uh thank you Mr
chairman and I uh call on the chairman
for a motion I'd like to make the
recommendation OTP on
1382 is there a
second thank you uh representative
Woodcock seconds the motion um
discussion by the maker of the motion
yes
um although I believe that sections one
and two are amply answered through
statutory language which we already have
in the military compact I see section
three as introducing legislation that's
required and needed in the uh reference
to students that are moving in that are
military oriented students that their
parents are in the service or actively
serving and this deals with uh fees
incurred by parents who are members of
the Armed Forces shall in due process
hearings be reimbursed by the Department
of Education if hearing officer finds in
favor of the parent I did not find any
language in the compact which allowed
that to occur so this is information I
think it's uh appropriate that we have
in this bill and we move it
forward thank you um represent Woodcock
do you want to
comment no no chairman cell thank you
but I do have a question for the the
maker of the motion we get there okay
goe with your question then thank you
chair I just my own edification um look
on this 26 on witness fees is there any
how expansive is that did you know or
what the May what is there a limitation
there no I I I couldn't tell you that
right now um I think it's going to vary
from situation
situation
um and I didn't see any reference to it
in the military compact when I read that
the other evening so I believe that's a
a valid Amendment or valid point to be
for us to be
considering uh in this legislation but I
can't give you a specific answer
represent whitcock on what the fees
might be I fall thank you I I appreciate
the the bill U and the help as you know
both on the same team um the but that I
think it's wide it makes me nervous how
wide open that could be that's all thank
you and if I can follow
quickly I think this is going to be a
rare thing occurring in this state uh
where people are very respectful of the
military and um I know that as a
principal as a principal over in Maine
when we had somebody come in down in
Brunswick or other
locations they hand carry their files
with them they're immediately you know
given the services they deserve
according to the I and if there's a need
to change that an i AP meeting is called
to go through the proc process to do it
uh correctly so uh I I I think this is
going to be an it may be on the books
here but I doubt very seriously if
you're going to see a lot of things
happening in the state regarding this
thank
you repent Miler thank you just a point
of clarification my sense is as I'm
reading this bill that if in fact um
there are
expenses uh that a parent would have in
pursuing this and they are are found in
favor of the parent that the department
not a local school district Etc would be
paying for that is is that am I reading
that
appropriately thank you ref
Cornell Thank you um I remember during
testimony um Jane B Rolo um from the
special education administrators had a
problem with lines 13 well 12 and 13
about I'm notified of a students
transfer to the district whether or not
the district schools are in session to
do an evaluation regarding the IEP and
they thought the timeline might be a
problem if someone moved into the
district in the end of June many school
districts aren't in session during the
summer so that 30 days might be imposing
a a difficult thing for them to
do thank you represent Heath thank you
Mr chair my question is basically a
followup um to uh representative
Cornell's um did I I thought we were
going to hear from and I probably wasn't
here when it happened the dep Department
of Education that how in fact that they
would um implement this and make sure
it's happening in the effective way that
this bill
purports um did you hear from them Mr
chair either either
chair which part of the bill are you
talking about I'm talking about fing up
on representative Cor
um the process of um implementing a what
this bill talks about is the hearing
process following up the timeline a lot
of the things that are listed in this
request
require an um really an abbreviated
timeline um which needs to be promptly
acted upon which as um representative
Cornell mentioned that it were to occur
during the sum
I think if somebody from the Department
of Ed um have they been brought into
this conversation and have they
responded in terms of how they would
implement this because we have a
situation that needs to be acted upon in
a quickly Manner and how would the
department of education do
this
1230 I not heard I I've not heard from
anybody and that could
be rectified within conducted within 30
school
days
simple um further
questions represent Woodcock I'm not
antagonist to this bill at all it's the
the the concern and I understand the
concern because um it was talking about
even if the school wasn't in session um
I think was the issue yeah I I see the
30 days um
the new I AP but there's a further
concern about if the school wasn't in
session um as L Rick said before it
probably won't be an issue but it could
very well be
right there needs to be a plan yeah
because yes line 13 Mr chair says if if
if they're absent session uh Glenn
whether or not the district schools are
in session I think that was the concern
perhaps represent Cornell was bringing
forward d
right thank you
so um chair lad's remarked that this
concern could be resolved if it said 30
school days I think that we need an
amendment to the bill to say that
representing a number of very small
school districts where the number of
staff to do this they don't even
necessarily have full-time special ed
staff if that one person is on vacation
in the summer they're simply not
available to do this
um I can't vote for the bill the way it
is uh rep of
like are there IEP Provisions that are
provided to students who need Services
continually throughout the summer so
that they don't fall behind and if we
make it 30 school
days could that then mean that those
stud students don't get the services
they need when school is not in
session the the reference you're making
ref Le is is to receive that length a
school year you have to identify that
within the individual education plan
right it would be in their plan that
they brought with them well if it's in
their plan coming with them then the
school would have to provide those
Services because it it says right within
current law that that we follow the the
uh materials being brought by the parent
even though it may not be an official
record those are the the that's the we
used to call it the old 2011 file that's
the the material which um would have to
be uh
followed further uh
discussion I'll just point out that um I
did receive an email from um uh Melissa
wette who uh testified from the
Department of uh justice the Northeast
the aison that um after uh sitting in on
the hearing and looking at the compact
they are still uh the dod is still
interested in moving forward with this
bill um if we can and I also heard from
um the uh Prime sponsor chairman uh Roy
who uh worked with with the uhu uh
Department of Defense must wed on this
legislation and he uh also is um anxious
to see it uh move forward uh to support
our military
families further
discussion yeah representative lad um
there are many schools in the state
which are small small schools they close
the door and they lock up in the
summertime uh you're not going to find
an administrator or a principal at that
time they're probably gone to the four
different directions um so if if this is
a concern and because we're at least I
am very interested in supporting
children of military families that need
this type of service I would suggest
that we not go any further with it right
now and see if we can get some amending
language to rectify this situation that
uh Jane berson present presented to
us and have that come back to us you
know as soon as we can get that amending
language
completed uh you
I'm yeah represent Woodcock thanks Mr
chair we do that in the time frame we
need for this bill yeah because it's not
an early Bill okay thank you thank you
can
I can I just ask about the department if
if in fact it's a small school wouldn't
there be person at the department of Ed
should be notified by the family or by
the people that are helping the military
family be coordinated so in fact the
department of Ed should be able to
assist in facilitating a smooth
transition and I just somehow some way
it seems like they should be part of the
role of all of this I mean that's what
the department of Ed
does thank you representative lakus
so my question and I was thinking along
those same
lines um if it's a small school and they
close up from the summer would somebody
from the doe be able to do the necessary
within 30 days review Etc um does it
have to be somebody from the school I
yeah I don't I know how that works
but I I think if I'm reading it
correctly all this required is an
evaluation within 30 days
right further
comment well yeah go ahead yes chairman
lad
the the school doesn't have to have an
evaluation they may upon receiving the
official record recognize that IEP
that's a current IEP and move forward
with that
IEP so an i an evaluation is not
necessarily going to have to happen uh
the only concern I see here if in fact
the student has wording within the IEP
saying that the education program will
continue through these summer months how
do we make sure that that is adhered to
and I think that can be rectified if we
can contact the director over there
special education At Doe right now miss
f
and and and try to get some guidance on
that so we can move forward with some
amending language which rectifies this
section of the
bill the section we're talking about
right here the notification and the
evaluation etc etc but the I hope
everybody's taken a look at the military
compact which is on page 65 which
specifically addresses special education
services we got to be in compliance with
idea
or the
501 chair cordelli yes when
representative lad contacts uh doe for
that clarification is it possible we
could fig find out a little more about
the witness fees at the same
time I I would expect so yeah I'm at 504
not 501 we're talking different thank
you yeah yeah I think that we can talk
to the department and the Department of
Defense possibly as well
um get everybody on the same page thank
you may I ask
the hear a question
yeah sir um would you like to step
forward
and
Absolutely I'll do my best is it Warren
Perry so for the record Warren Perry
Deputy a general department of military
Affairs and veteran services thank you
very much I I have a question
um your office probably works with not
just folks in our state but communicates
with the military compact uh situation
throughout the country um are there any
other states that might have this type
of language that may have a way of
addressing the issues we've been
discussing today yes there are so we we
I our department generally focuses
inside the state we work with the State
Defense lay on officer Miss Melissa
wette who who does this kind of the
Nationwide policy uh proponency for the
country right so she's already she's
indicated to me while she's watching the
hearing uh she can't travel uh right now
but she's watching the hearing indicated
that uh the folks from Texas may have
some language that would be able to help
us kind of work through
this that be good if she could get that
emailed to us as quickly as possible uh
then that we could move on it we do have
a deadline that's middle of March I
think probably in a couple of days we
can have something that's ready to go
and and the I just want to make sure
she's watching so I just want to make
sure that the concern is the 30 days
over the summer is the is the biggest
concern and how can we mitigate the
impact of the potential for small school
districts or having the Department of
Education step in where smaller school
districts couldn't is that that
generally the conversation I hear that
right I believe of nodded heads and
representative Woodcock you wanted
another point to be looked at thank you
if if this uh if they have other Lang
that would give us more clarity on the
witness fees portion of this uh what
that actually like how expansive that
could be yes sir okay thank you so she's
texting me as as we speak so if if you
big absolutely from other states she
said she can get those best practices
from the other states she's working that
right now I don't know I she's generally
responsive I I can't imagine it's going
to take her to the end of the week to
get things right thank you um pretty
good representative Heath just one other
thing um as a result of the actions
being taken shouldn't a technical
assistance be sent out to all school
districts um and schools knowing what
they would do in the event that a
military family arrives with a child
with a um an IEP so they're updated on
all the it's only for you the school
districts to have this information is
that I hope that's part of the um I
would think that that would fall into
purview of the Department of Education
that's exactly where it belongs we need
to to the director and and make sure
they follow up on it too once we can get
some of this information back
from great thank you very much for your
help
um uh anything further for Mr
Perry seeing nothing thank you very
much um anything further from the
committee otherwise um we'll put this on
hold we'll get the uh best practic
language from other states and um see
about amending uh
1382 okay I think that's it
right EXC yeah were we going to hear
from someone at the department about
special ed
rules explain a little bit more Cornell
in now Federal Law requires that all
IEPs be reviewed within 30 days anyway
whether it's summer or not when a
student moves into the district I think
so
I'm wondering if this isn't I'm confused
about if this is a problem or not no
that's done locally um that's done when
when a student moves in that has an IEP
let's say it's in Speech
Pathology uh the speech therapist and
that intervention team would be looking
at the transfer student student coming
in look at that I AP the speech
therapist would most likely meet with
that student and parent determine yes
this IEP is still current and that
proposed so we're going to just follow
it there an evaluation does not have to
occur I don't mean evaluation reviewing
the IEP that's always done if they move
in during the summer it happens anyway
then too doesn't it no okay no it opens
when the school doors open up and the
student arrives for the next school year
yeah thank you you're
welcome Al righty so we've gone through
the bills for today that we're going to
be discussing we will try to gather more
information
regarding all these other bills we'll
make a contact with the special people
over at Department of Education
today and and try to get some uh
information back from them so with that
we're going to close the executive
sessions for
today and hope everybody has a good
afternoon Tom 10 a.m
y